vendredi 13 novembre
ce jour que nous n'oublierons jamais la
france a été frappée lâchement dans un
acte de guerre organisée de loin et
froidement exécuté une horde d'assassins
a tué 130 des nôtres et en a blessé des
centaines au nom d'une cause folle et
d'un dieu trahir aujourd'hui la nation
toute entière
ses forces vives pleure les victimes
cent trente noms 130 vie arrachée 130
destin faucher 130 rire que l'on
n'entendra plus 130 voix qui a jamais se
sont tus ces femmes ces hommes
incarnez le bonheur de vivre c'est parce
qu'ils étaient la vie qu'ils ont été
tués c'est parce qu'ils étaient la
france qu'ils ont été abattus c'est
parce qu'ils étaient la liberté qu'ils
ont été massacrés en cet instant si
grave
et si douloureux où la nation fait corps
avec elle même j'adresse en son nom
notre compassion notre affection
notre sollicitude aux familles et aux
proches réunis ici dans ce même malheur
des parents qui ne vont plus verront
plus leurs enfants des enfants qui
grandiront sans leurs parents
des couples brisés par la perte de
l'être aimé des frères et des soeurs
pour toujours séparés 139 étant de
blessés marqué à jamais marqués dans
leur chair
traumatisée au plus profond d'eux mêmes
alors je veux dire simplement ses mots
la france sera à vos côtés nous
rassemblerons nos forces pour apaiser
les douleurs et après avoir enterré les
morts il nous reviendra de réparer les
vivants a vous tous je vous promets
solennellement que la france mettra tout
en oeuvre pour détruire l'armée des
fanatiques qui ont commis ces crimes
qu'elle agira sans répit pour protéger
ses enfants
je vous promets aussi
que la france restera elle même telle
que les disparus l'avait aimée est telle
qu'ils auraient voulu qu'elle demeure s
il fallait une raison de nous tenir
debout aujourd'hui une raison de nous
battre pour nos principes
une raison de défendre cette république
qui est notre bien commun
nous nous trouverions dans leurs
souvenirs
ces femmes ces hommes venaient de plus
de 50 communes de france deux villes de
banlieue de village il venait aussi du
monde
dix sept pays portent aujourd'hui avec
nous le deuil
ces femmes ces hommes en ce vendredi 13
devant était à paris une ville qui donne
un manteau de lumière aux idées une
ville qui vibre le jour et qui brille la
nuit il était sur les terrasses des
cafés
ces lieux de passage ouverts aux
rencontres et aux idées ils partageaient
un repas aux saveurs du monde dans cette
soirée où l'automne ne paraissait pas
finir il chantait au bataclan aus/honda
sdat groupe américain qui leur faisait
l'amitié de se produire dans une salle
qui depuis deux siècles incarne l'esprit
de paris ces hommes
ces femmes avaient tous les âges mais la
plupart avaient moins de 35 ans ils
étaient des enfants lors de la chute du
mur de berlin il n'avait pas eu le temps
de croire à la fin de l'histoire
elle les avait déjà rattrapé quand
survint le 11 septembre 2001 il avait
alors compris que le monde était guettée
par de nouveaux périls les attentats du
début de l'année les avait bouleversé
beaucoup je laissais avait tenu à
manifester le 11 janvier
comme des millions de français ils
avaient dit leur refus de céder face à
la menace terroriste
il savait que la france n'est l'ennemi
d'aucun peuple que ces soldats se porte
l'art on les appelle pour protéger les
plus faibles et non pour assouvir une
quelconque domination
ces femmes ces hommes étaient la
jeunesse de france
la jeunesse d'un peuple libre qui chérit
la culture la sienne c'est à dire toutes
les cultures
parmi les victimes du bataclan
beaucoup avaient fait de la musique leur
métier c'est cette musique qui était
insupportable aux terroristes c'est
cette harmonie qu'il voulait cassé brisé
c'est cette joie qu'ils voulaient
ensevelir dans le fracas de leurs bombes
et bien il ne l'arrêteront pas et comme
pour mieux leur répondre nous
multiplierons les chansons des concerts
les spectacles
nous continuerons à aller dans les
stades et notamment au stade si bien
nommé le stade de france à saint denis
nous participerons au grand rendez vous
sportif comme on rencontre les plus
modestes et nous pourrons aussi
communier dans les mêmes émotions en
faisant fi de nos différences de nos
origines de couleur de nos convictions
de nos croyances de nos confessions car
nous sommes une seule et même nation
porté par les mêmes valeurs que veulent
les terroristes nous diviser nous
opposer jeter les uns contre les autres
je voulais sûr ils échoueront ils ont le
culte de la mort mais nous nous nous
avons l'amour l'amour de la vie ceux qui
sont tombés le 13 novembre était la
france toute la france il était étudiant
journaliste enseignant restaurateurs
ingénieurs chauffeur avocat graphiste
architecte mais aussi charpentier
serveurs photographe fonctionnaires
publicitaire vendeurs artistes ils
étaient les métiers de la france
les talents du monde tous voulaient
réussir pour eux mêmes pour leurs
familles pour leur pays c'est en nous
rappelant leurs visages leurs noms mais
aussi leur espoir leur joie leur rêve
anéanti que nous agirons demain nous
connaissons les demies c'est la haine
celle qui tue à bamako à tunis à palmyre
à copenhague à paris et qui a tué n'a
guère à londres ou à madrid
l'ennemi c'est le fanatisme qui veut
soumettre l'homme un ordre inhumain
c'est l'obscurantisme
c'est à dire un islam des voiliers qui
renie le message de son livre sacré
cet ennemi nous vous vaincrons ensemble
avec nos forces
celle de la république avec nos armes
celle de la démocratie avec nos
institutions avec le droit dans ce
combat
nous pouvons compter sur nos militaires
engagés sur des opérations difficiles en
syrie en irak ou sahel nous pouvons
compter sur nos policiers et nos
gendarmes en lien avec la justice qui se
sont encore comporter de façon admirable
pour mettre hors d'état de nuire les
terroristes nous pouvons compter sur le
parlement pour adopter toutes les
mesures qu appelle la défense des
intérêts du pays dans un esprit de
concorde nationale et dans le respect
des libertés fondamentales
et puis et puis surtout nous pouvons
compter sur chaque française et sur
chaque français pour faire preuve de
vigilance de résolution d'humanité de
dignité
nous mènerons ce combat jusqu'au bout et
nous le gagnerons en étant fidèle à
l'idée même de la france qu'elle est
elle un art de vivre une volonté
farouche d'être ensemble
un attachement à la laïcité une
appartenance à la nation une confiance
dans notre destin collectif je vous
l'affirmé ici nous ne changerons pas
nous serons unis unis sur l'essentiel et
je salue ici devant vous famille ses
innombrables geste de tant de français
anonymes qui se sont pressés sur les
lieux des drames pour allumer une bougie
déposé un bouquet laissé un message
apporté un dessin et si l'on cherche un
mot
pour qualifier cet élan ce mot existe
c'est la fraternité dans la devise de la
république
et que dire de la mobilisation de tous
les services publics pour porter secours
et assistance aux victimes
pour accompagner les survivants pour
soutenir les proches ses personnels de
santé admirable leur action dit aussi ce
que nous sommes un pays solidaire tout
ce qui s'est passé depuis le 13 novembre
porte la marque de la gravité de la
conscience des défis qui se présentent à
notre pays ceux qui sont tombés le 13
novembre incarner nos valeurs et notre
devoir est plus que jamais de les faire
vivre ces valeurs nous ne céderons ni à
la peur ni à la haine et si la colère
nous saisit nous la mettrons au service
de la calme détermination à défendre la
liberté au jour le jour c'est à dire la
volonté
de faire de la france un grand pays fier
de son histoire de son mode de vie de sa
culture de son rayonnement de son idéal
universel du respect et même de la
ferveur tu que notre pays inspire au
monde
chaque fois qu'il est blessé je n'oublie
pas 18 les images venus de la planète
entière
célébrant dans le même mouvement le
sacrifice de ceux qui étaient tombés à
paris comme si c'était le monde entier
qui se couvrait de deuil
le patriotisme que nous voyons
aujourd'hui se manifester avec ses
drapeaux fièrement arborer ces
rassemblements spontanés
ces foules qui chantent la marseillaise
oui tout cela n'a rien à voir avec je ne
sais quel instinct de revanche ou je ne
sais quel rejet de l'autre ce
patriotisme le symbole de notre union
notre inaltérable résistance face aux
coûts qui peuvent nous être portée car
la france garde intacte malgré le drame
malgré le sang versé ces principes
d'espérance et de tolérance l'épreuve
nous a tous meurtris les familles
d'abord les français quelles que soient
leurs conditions leur confession leur
origine l'épreuve de à tous meurtris
mais elle nous rendra plus forts je vais
vous dire la confiance de la génération
qui vient
avant elle d'autres générations ont
connu à la fleur de l'âge des événements
tragiques qui ont forgé leur identité
l'attak du 13 novembre restera dans la
mémoire de la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui
comme une initiation terrible à la
dureté du monde mais aussi comme une
invitation à l'affronter en inventant un
nouvel engagement
je sais que cette génération tiendra
solidement le flambeau que nous lui
transmettons je suis sûr qu'elle aura le
courage de prendre pleinement en main
l'avenir de notre nation
le malheur qui a touché les martyrs du
13 devant investi cette jeunesse de
cette grande et noble tâche la liberté
ne demande pas à être vengé
mais à être servi je salue cette
génération nouvelle elle a été frappée
elle n'est pas effrayée elle est lucide
et entreprenante
à l'image des innocents deux nous
portons le deuil elle saura
j'en suis convaincu faire preuve de
grandeur
elle vivra elle vivra pleinement au nom
des morts que nous pleurons aujourd'hui
malgré les larmes
cette génération est aujourd'hui devenue
le visage de la france vive la
république et vive la france
de quoi
voilà
à
ouais
e
c
oui